i love cheeseburgers oh man but
i'm gonna have to really
curtail it because i'm about to be going
on tour soon
got a twitter new album yeah man
you uh i love cheese can you give me
if you could rank the top five fast food
cheeseburgers from one to five
we're talking major chains not talking
like the spot on the corner that you
love if we had to go from one to five
best fast food burgers because i always
fight with people about how good
mcdonald's is because i think it's fire
i'ma be honest it's not the burger it's
the mustard the onions the ketchup and
the pickles at mcdonald's that make day
cheese and then you put the fries on the
burger you do that too
[Laughter]
i get that number nine with the two
cheeseburgers do you ever dip it dip
your burger barbecue sauce of course
of course
with the fries oh god please no i love
mcdonald's i'd be like yo if mcdonald's
was trash it wouldn't be the number one
restaurant in the world now it might be
trash for you
but
oh all things and all things in
moderation yeah and everybody got
something on that mcdonald's menu they
[ __ ] with yeah i love the pancakes oh
the [ __ ] hot cakes i get the hot
cakes yes and i put the i put the butter
on there and then i put strawberry jelly
on there then i drizzle the serve that's
why i like that mcgriddle because but
i'm weird though they got this
restaurant called raisin canes
the best [ __ ] sauce i go get it i go
get the pancakes
and i go get wendy's french fries and i
go get raisin cans chicken fingers and i
eat i rap
i'm weird i wrap my i wrapped my chicken
finger inside the pancake
do you introduce the cane sauce into
this equation i got to and the honey
mustard yeah
so let me get this straight you'll go to
mcdonald's
get me i mean listen me and you both
we're on the same wavelength of fat
[ __ ] here we
food tastes better when you wait till
your cheat day that's real because it's
almost like like on mondays i'd be like
six more days
so let me get this straight though i
don't want to just pass this over you'll
go to mcdonald's you'll get the hotcakes
you'll go to wendy's you'll get there
first get like 10 orders a hot cake
you'll get
wendy's fries wendy's fries with the
windows barbecue sauce which is the best
barbecue sauce yeah it is
and then you get raisin cane's chicken
raisin cane and we just combine all
three on a cheat day into some just
metamorphically amazing
i take all of my pancakes people just
sit down watch me i put the
i put the butter on them i put the
strawberry jelly i put a little bit of
syrup
i take my
my um wendy's fries
it's so weird my process i put all my
wendy's fries down i put my chicken
fingers across them
i take the lemons and i squeeze my
lemons across it i drizzle the hot sauce
across it then i take the barbecue sauce
and dribble my barbecue sauce across
then i put my fries and my chicken
finger on my um i make like a little
burrito on on a hat cake
and i just eat it and people be like
what do you do with the cane sauce also
i dip it okay okay okay i just dip it
like every other bite i might dip it
from
from the raisin cane sauce to the honey
mustard or vice versa no man i'm i'm but
i'm not gonna lie i'm intrigued you
talking to the same person that put
strawberry jelly and grape jelly on
their cheeseburgers
i've actually uh i'm just weird i went
to some like fancy place recently and
they had um
i bought a cheeseburger and i had bacon
jam
yeah they've been doing the bacon jam i
don't care for that i don't eat pork
yeah but it was it wasn't bad i i
understand
like your logic there i just can't
because i know the
i know the truth behind it so i can't
you can't eat the swine i just can't eat
it they don't have any veins
that is kind of crazy they don't detox
and they'll eat anything
but they really like some of the
smartest animals on earth
they're super smart they're survivors
they're super smart but i just because
they got them sometimes they used to run
across my land
on my farm you see them in the morning
and they got a way they communicate with
each other and everything they like
little people
well you're muslim muslims can't eat pig
am i getting is that right yeah i don't
eat poor